This airplane's only purpose is to
deliver nuclear weapon launch codes to
our submarines in the Middle East. Is
America about to nuke Iran?
I want to invite you to add something
powerful to your sadaqah jariyah list.
We're on a mission
>> to teach tens of thousands of people
around the world
>> how to pray salah properly.
>> Just imagine this. You help someone
learn with you how to pray. How to
recite Surah al-Fatiha. Every Fajr,
Dhuhr, Asr, Maghrib,
>> Isha, Tahajjud,
>> Tarawih. Every prayer for the rest of
their lives, you share in the reward.
>> When they teach their children, and
their children's children,
the reward continues for you.
>> For just £100, you can help teach 20 to
60 people
>> like me learn salah. Donate today and
earn rewards that never stop.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh, brothers and sisters and
dear friends. Is America about to nuke
Iran? Here's a video, subhanallah, of
them, and it's been spotted that they
are sending the E-6B
Mercury plane, which is instructed, and
its whole point of what the plane is,
which we're going to find out I'm going
to information of what this plane's
about, what its objective is about, it's
that anytime there is a threat and the
command center on the ground has been
attacked, this plane can stay airborne
for 72 hours, and the command there, the
codes are given for nuclear strikes to
be taken. This plane was spotted heading
towards
the Middle East. Is it a threat? Is it a
um you know, a a a bluff, or is it what
we think it is, that America is losing
the war, and they are going to resort to
this to save face with the Operation
Epic Fury, sorry, Epstein Fury. Uh let's
watch this video.
This right here is no ordinary plane.
This is the E-6B Mercury, an aircraft
that was just sent to the Middle East.
And do you know what its primary purpose
is? Let me tell you. This airplane's
only purpose is to deliver nuclear
weapon launch codes to our submarines in
the Middle East. There is no other
purpose whatsoever for this plane's
existence. That's its sole reason for
even existing. And why was it sent to
the Middle East? Does, I don't know,
Iran have nuclear weapons? No. Does
anybody else in the Middle East other
than Israel have nuclear weapons? No.
So, why would you need this plane there?
Well, there's a lot of people out there
thinking that if this war continues to
drag on,
that Donald Trump, who has wanted so
badly to be the first president in this
century
to launch a nuclear weapon against an
enemy,
is just itching to do it.
And we're going to do it.
Because there's a lot of analysts that
believe with modern nuclear technology
and the fact that Tehran is surrounded
by mountains to shield from the nuclear
fallout, that we can nuke Tehran
and not suffer any consequences.
Just 10 million people dead.
Let that sink in.
Is it time yet?
I'm just asking. Is it time to let this
continue? Well, there you go. That video
was showing that. Now, I'm going to read
an article from Daily Mail, brothers and
sisters, subhanallah, to give a
perspective on this. And I'm going to
show you guys a video explaining what
that bomb and that plane's job exactly,
so we get an idea. And it's very
important for us to be clued up about
this, brothers and sisters, from the
geopolitical wars. Trump deploys
doomsday nuclear command plane to the
Middle East as World War III fears
surge. So, the US military terrifying
Doomsday planes have taken the skies as
fears as a nuclear war inch closer to
reality.
Flight tracking data has captured
multiple launches of the Navy's E-6B
Mercury strategic airborne command
aircraft since the war on Iran began on
February 28th. These giant planes
constructed using the frames of the
Boeing 707 are built to survive a
nuclear war and coordinate America's
military response from air.
Specifically, the plane serves as a
flying radio station or command center
for President and the Secretary of War
carrying special antennas that can even
reach nuclear armed submarines deep
under water. Along with being able to
talk to satellites and land-based
military posts
and underground missing missile
facilities.
The Mercury fleet is capable of
controlling a nuclear strike should
World War break out and US was already
on the attack.
The two two E-6B Mercury flights were
spotted over the US on March the 2nd,
one traveling from the Gulf Coast and
landing at the Naval Air Station at
Patuxent River in Maryland and the other
taking off from and later landing back
at Offutt Air Force Base in Nebraska.
Since those flights, there have been
reports from military news outlets of
more F-6B launches heading across the
Atlantic to the Persian Gulf. The
Pentagon declined to comment on the
reported flights due to operation
security. So, as you can see bro
sisters, this matter is really getting
more serious serious. Now, can they do
it? Now, there's a possibility. Why?
Now, America has to like they say
strategically in a war has to be has to
show their strength that absolute this
decimation, annihilation of the Iranian
government and its people. Yes, I think
it's IRGCC. Now,
for Iran to win this war, all it has to
do not is not to lose the war.
Because it's the underdog. If not, what
Iran is showing is their capabilities
with their latest uh missile with their
ballistic missiles and their cluster
bombs
is that they are now more advanced and
more strategic and more complex with
their uh with their attacks on the Dubai
airports, Qatar, Kuwait and other areas.
So, which shows what? That Americans are
like, "Hold on a second. We was not
expecting this." Now, we also know know
that when Iran sends missiles they've
been intercepted from over Iraq,
Jordan, neighboring countries, maybe
Egypt, fighter jets, the submarines and
the fighter ships are shooting this
down. So, it's even a miracle that
anything has landed Israel. And now,
Israel has caused called the people that
if anyone records and offers Jews have
been doing that, yes, record uh the
damage that's been carried out in Tel
Aviv, there's a 5-year prison. They're
hiding this because they can see the
catastrophic destruction and every
couple of million pounds of missile to
stop a drone or a ballistic missile
coming from Iran is costing millions of
pounds, whereas for Iran, it's costing
them a couple of hundred thousand
pounds. So, this is becoming a war of
who is going to run out of ammunition
first. So, it is looking stark, but I
believe because of this risk of even
having the reputation of losing a war,
the pedophiles at the top in the Epstein
Islands, these pedos who are raping
American little children
uh and send them to islands so they can
blackmail the elite to ask them to send
their grown children to die for Iran for
for Israel. Uh brothers and sisters,
it's clear. And they will do anything to
save their reputation cuz they don't
care about anyone. They killed 160
innocent Iranian girls in school. So,
subhanallah brothers and sisters,
what I'm going to say is wallahi, it's
crazy what's going on. But, again,
people are talking about when's the day
of judgment? Forget the day of judgment.
When you die, your day of judgment
starts. So, invest where it matters
because
the Dajjal is going to come, this is
going to come. Okay, no problem. Don't
worry about that. The day you die, that
the prophet said, is the day your day of
judgement starts. What have you done and
what have you brought forth?
That's the question. And brothers and
sisters, we are a charity, Salah Pro. We
are helping teach
thousands of people to learn Salah.
Where did your donations go? The link is
there. One-to-one Salah instructors that
teach brothers and sisters around the
world, reverts and those who don't know
how to pray Salah to learn Salah. We've
printed 80,000 mats, guided prayer mats
that come with a wudu guide, Surah
Fatiha, Surah Ikhlas on the mat, and how
to pray Salah. We're printing another
70,000, that means we've printed
150,000. Number three, your donation
goes towards a Salah Pro app that we
spent $60,000 on and we're trying to get
1 million downloads. And every action
that's done on there, you get the
reward. Salah instructors, book a Salah
instructor, order a guided prayer mat,
Salah times, Qibla finder, watch videos
on how to pray Salah, find your local
Salah hub, you get the reward. And last
lastly,
one of the things that we do is Salah
hubs. We work with masajid to do Salah
lessons, brothers and sisters. Go to the
link and donate whatever amount you can,
brothers and sisters. May Allah bless
you guys. We will be going to Mecca,
inshallah, if Allah wills, and we'll be
doing lives there. Please join,
inshallah, this campaign. May Allah
protect us. Till next time.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. Invest in your sadaqah
jariyah now cuz you don't know what's
going to happen tomorrow with the
current news that we brought you.
Goodbye.